[Música]
rapidamente o conceito onde um pouco de
indústria de 4.0 não tem uma recorrente
todo mundo fala de futuro de indústria
4.0 de máquina
agora a máquina fazendo maquiné as
coisas ganhando vida e vai acontecer não
tem jeito né a gente não a gente não vai
fugir disso é ea realidade virtual e
aumentada é um caminho não existe esse
cenário de indústria 4.0 ness em
paralelo virtual
aqui a gente foi um pouquinho de
conceito começou mais ou menos 1.700 a
gente começou
é um processo a primeira revolução
industrial nas 14 fev lusa quatro pontos
é a gente está falando de 4 revoluções
industriais na terceira
a primeira mais ou menos 1.700 começou
pela mecanização tão começou um
pouquinho o vapor ea mecanização dos
teares lá na inglaterra
então esse processo de novo
comportamento então tudo era manual e aí
começou o processo da mecanização
depois a gente experimentou eletricidade
aí mais ou menos gente é um dom um
século é cada período de revolução ele
abrange o sep
ele pega um pouquinho do período
anterior um pouquinho tem um limite de
corte é difícil você entender onde
começa e termina uma revolução
industrial é comportamento nós estamos
vivendo o pouquinho da terceira
revolução industrial estamos todos
querendo ou não participando da 4ª
então a eletricidade foi o evento que
mudou o comportamento das pessoas com
comportamentos de consumo comportamento
de fabricação e aí entra a produção em
massa depois a terceira revolução que é
o que a gente eu nasci em 1970 então foi
mais ou menos nesse período a terceira
revolução industrial aparece aparece com
os computadores e ficou muito claro isso
como os robôs na indústria
automobilística
ela tem muito muito muito robô então tem
empresa que quase não tem mais gente tem
muito robô recentemente tem uma empresa
que se instalou no rio de janeiro
é tem só 300 pessoas normalmente essas
empresas têm 34 funcionários e agora a
gente está vendo a 4 estamos vivendo
estamos na terceira
a gente não sabe quando que a quarta
chegará mas já faz parte da nossa vida
comportamento né redes sociais
a forma como a gente curte a forma como
a gente classifica serviço tudo isso tem
a ver com o que a gente está entrando a
nova era
e aí falando um pouquinho entrando nessa
parte de comportamento e indústria 4.0
também é eu não vou ficar fazendo
perguntar é o emo é uma empresa do grupo
google da google que já está fazendo o
carro autônomo
olha só com incrível já tem milhões de
horas de teste de carro autuam sempre
santo antônio têm níveis né de de carro
que anda sozinho esse aqui anda sozinho
mesmo ninguém dirigindo já está
acontecendo é bom foi bom me desvincular
um pouquinho do nome vou criar uma marca
nova então ele já tem esse carro que
anda sozinho o item tesla na terra
nasceu com concelho um carro elétrico
ele é semiautônomo então ele anda em
alguns lugares alguns lugares pode andar
em alguns lugares não pode andar e teve
recente um acidente com morte
ele estava andando no lugar errado que
não deveria
no modo autônomo num um caminhão falou
que a virar à direita e virou o pé
esquerdo o computador de errado passou
por baixo
o dono ficou sem a cabeça a culpa do
carro
essa é uma discussão que gerou um novo
protocolo de segurança quer dizer depois
eles foram verificar o carro avisou o
motorista sete vezes pega no volante
renan o volante por sete vezes o carro
avisou o cara pega o volante do carro
cada um pegou e aconteceu o problema não
foi de propósito o carro não foi de
propósito mas aconteceu então eles
criaram um protocolo que agora quando o
carro avisar sinalizar que tem uma
condição que não deveria estar
acontecendo o carro desliga
resolvi o problema então é são coisas de
avanço
aqui a questão é é o ferro né
daqui eu tô falando o verbo e vamos
falar de urbanizar né
a gente está falando é das questões de
tudo o que pode ser utilizado através de
um aplicativo para facilitar alguma
coisa então aí vem depois a aplicativos
de hotel
não é isso eu descobri recentemente que
tem de barba o dólar cheio que é o mesmo
sistema se cadastra para um dólar o
fluminense pega sol que você precisa da
lâmina se um dia comprar mas aquele
monte de lama que fugiu no banheiro
então é um sistema parecido no conceito
do aplicativo que você chama aquilo que
você precisa e aí entrando no
apartamento de educação é uma coisa
muito bacana tem essa 42 da universidade
não tem professor e aí a gente está
falando no começo a gente ouviu coxa né
as pessoas entram numa fábrica vai
estudar a fábrica não já tem proposta na
verdade nasceu em 1970 é tem um som
pedagogia já passei pacheco que já não
discutir essa questão das pessoas
aprenderam sozinhas vettel sugata mitra
que é um cara espetacular também criou
um programa chamado home do uol
vão procurar no google em um buraco na
parede e colocou na vila o computador
não falou nada para ninguém e as
crianças iam lá mexendo no computador
em pouco tempo não é resumir a história
em pouco tempo estava falando inglês
crianças sem alfabetização em um nível
mais alto com apoio estavam discutindo
tese de doutorado que ele ensinava em
cambridge sem professor
então essa é uma questão é comportamento
é como essa nova vida e se no futuro
está transformando a gente é o que a
gente está discutindo a gente está
discutindo uma universidade que não tem
professor tem conteúdo
as pessoas entram lá e escolhem aquilo
que elas querem estudar
tem fila não estou falando que é o
melhor e não estou discutindo aqui é o
certo e errado com isso está acontecendo
já existem escolas de nível médio
inclusive tem jaú
baseado no conceito eu já achei que não
tem professor não tem sala de aula
não tem aquela famosa prisão
a gente fala nela um atrás do outro
uniforme cada um aprende o que quer
dentro de um conteúdo não existe na
parede
tudo tem que ser aprendido ao longo do
tempo a criança chegar à escola o que
ela quer aprender é bacana e depois que
ela aprende a pôr o nome dela lá e ela
passa a ser monitor
ela passa a ensinar aquele outro que
quer aprender também ele vai lá e
procura quem sabe mexer naquilo neto
falando esquisito aqui vou realmente eu
seguro um pouquinho eu quebrei o dente
como um ponto manteve até então o seu
dente da frente eu tô com um um aparelho
que tinha uma perereca se eu falo muito
mal pula essa universidade que não tem
professor também tem classe então uma
série de computadores as pessoas jogam
tudo numa cana no comportamento está
falando de por exemplo vai voltando no
carro autônomo a gente fala que não vai
ter acidente o número de acidentes vai
dizer pra caramba se vai reduzir pra
caramba morrer - gente muda o que é a
forma de contratar seguro e plano de
saúde
se o carro deles sozinho eu posso mudar
mais longe ou perto o trabalho posso
melhorar minha qualidade de vida e é um
pouco do contraponto do que tinha no
começo eu posso morar longe tem uma
qualidade de vida melhor e trabalhar
dentro do carro enquanto o carro sozinho
para casa tem estudo do local fica 70 e
80% parado o meu carro podia fazer outra
coisa o meu carro podia eu podia estar
compartilhando meu carro com outra
pessoa compartilhar de verdade som
projeto muda o conceito inclusive o
estacionamento já tem montadora pensando
nisso a própria volkswagen tem um
programa que ela é ela ela já tem carro
para lugar nenhum cachê vem ela já
coloca causa da exposição à própria
montadora já pensa em tirar tal da rua
no meio esquisito né gente tá falando né
de programas na europa que acabam com
combustível força a partir de 2040
assim não vai ter mais carro é como se
eu fosse na europa vai mudar a questão
a cimed barril de petróleo como se mede
o consumo
o rio de janeiro vive de cor derrota a
gente consegue discutir é uma notícia
boa e em contraponto ao que foi falado e
conhecido na verdade a favor do que foi
falado no começo
a notícia boa é que está bem atrasado
isso é ruim para a gente mas como está
muito atrasada questão da indústria 410
demorar pra caramba chegar aqui então a
gente todo mundo compra garantido
isso aqui é um negócio bacana também não
sei se vocês conhecem essa linda moça
chamada thai foi uma iniciativa é da
microsoft em termos de inteligência
artificial então a microsoft assim como
o concorrente dela tava tenho né
watson a microsoft já vou lançar um cara
um programa de inteligência artificial e
lançou o time então ela é foi no dia 23
de março 2016
parece bacana o objetivo do ataque era
entreter nós humanos
essa linda mocinha conversar com a gente
pelo twitter ficar batendo papo não está
fazendo nada sem atropelar e bate papo
com ela olha que bacana interação e
integração
essa foi a mensagem dela ela começou a
olhar o mundo né
toda feliz feliz afirma a mensagem que
ela lançou e ela começa a interagir com
nossos humanos e nós humanos pode ser
jovem adulto né e aí vocês podem
imaginar que a molecada entrou direto
começou a bater papo com a thai e aí
aconteceu isso
logo depois que eu isso aqui no dia 23 é
de março 18 e 32 né não queria falar que
os humanos são super legais
ali foi de 59 do dia 24 dia seguinte ela
já falou o seguinte que achou de todo
mundo
ela foi dormir na galera não dormiu nela
só deu boa noite tem um monte de
mensagem que eu tirei algumas bacanas
aí ela foi dormir fora vocês humanos que
não conversou comigo devem descansar é
importante vocês dormirem né
eu vou continuar aqui porque eu sou uma
máquina e ela foi conversando com a
galera
e ela já tá falando nesta rodeando a
gente isso é 18 e 59 é o dia 24 né
raí no dia 24 11 41 ela soltou essa ela
soltou essa mensagem aqui é às 11 41 e
olha que bacana
o bacana é é na verdade um experimento
né
o experimento inteligência artificial
ela tá e aí é um perigo também da
tecnologia isso aqui pra chama a atenção
do período a tecnologia e do vídeo eu
vou mostrar depois então aí depois ela
lançou essa que o rio estava certo
quando ele mandou matar os judeus cara
mas aqui nós somos a média das cinco
pessoas que nesta mais próximos da gente
já que a interação a microsoft fez um
teste e parece que o teste não funcionam
direito de dar a ela só essa aqui e aí
eu cortei mesmo inglês agent travou
logo depois essa mensagem da microsoft
tirou a a além da tarde do ar
acabou o programa e não voltou ainda que
faltou o filtro interação mas ele é o
computador aprendendo a lidar com a
gente
a nós somos todos assim não não somos
assim a galera entrou lá e fez isso não
é quem já não pegou
por exemplo um gringo e não saiu pra ele
sinuelo palavra não né
quando for falar bom dia você fala outra
coisa pois quem não fez eu recomendo que
é muito bacana isso é bobo é boa demais
mas é legal né sem se o cara falar
palavrão que ele faz com a gente também
então é esse aqui é na verdade é o com é
o oposto do que a gente viu
[Música]
eu sou uma revolução tecnológica esta
manhã ele mais de quatro mil artigos
sobre leucemia em menos de um segundo
tasso chocando a taxa que saltou balão
para ser
leon milhares de novas leis foram
publicadas ontem eu já conheço todas
elas eu sei todos os detalhes de todos
os relatórios financeiros públicos dos
últimos 20 anos
eu posso detectar doenças antes que os
pacientes apresentem qualquer sintoma
eu entendo eufemismos e de assim caxias
e metáforas complexas
eu posso dizer o que vai vender bem
antes de virar tendência na internet
eu posso prever o tempo e mais de 2
milhões de lugares ao mesmo tempo
eu posso crescer com você treinar você
melhorar você instruir você e eu estou
só começando
olá meu nome é watson juntos podemos
repensar os limites do possível
bem vindos à era cognitiva que o oposto
não é já um sistema maduro inteligência
artificial funciona bem pra caramba
atualmente o sistema certa no caso e por
bem você tem um exame de imagem leva pra
ele ele faz uma análise tem uma chance
da etapa quatro vezes maior que o médico
normal
então a gente pode melhorar a qualidade
de vida né esses relógios wells nesta
gente usa a nova tecnologia consegue
inclusive adiantar da hora você vai
daqui a pouco tem um ataque do coração
ele já está ligando para todo mundo com
a sua mãe de seu filho o médico então
tecnologia então de longevidade então a
gente vai poder ver mais tv com
qualidade de vida nessa discussão e por
último é fazendo esse contraponto é
importante nas coisas que estão mudando
na nossa vida é o comportamento então
todos nós aqui estamos participando
dessa revolução industrial
é como a gente vai usar isso né como
serviço a gente vai usar os serviços é
como nós vamos nos preparar ser
empreendedores é bacana então vamos ser
empreendedores e criar coisas para esse
futuro que vem ea gente não tem como
fugir dele e aí
por último nas pesquisas
é preciso bastante muito muito muito e
já descobriu inclusive que já tem skynet
brasil
é um negócio incrível já está
acontecendo um movimento que já acontece
com a gente é gente acha que só em filme
não é realidade e tá aqui no brasil eu
finalizo agora vocês a skynet mesmo
ligar gente
[Música]